I think the criticism that people would
uh would say about your uh talking about
covet and maybe you can correct me but
you were skeptical or you were against
skepticism of the safety and efficacy of
the vaccine
so people who get nervous about
the vaccine but don't fall into the
usual anti-vax Camp which I think there
was a significant yeah enough number oh
yeah they're asking they're getting
nervous I mean I especially after the
warn of Afghanistan and Iraq I too was
nervous about anything where a lot of
money could be made
and you start you just see how the
people who are greedy who come they come
to the surface all of a sudden and a lot
of them that run institutions actually
really good human beings and I know a
lot of them but it's hard to know
how those two combined together when
there's hundreds of billions trillions
of dollars to be made and so that's
skepticism I I guess you this the sense
was that you weren't open enough to the
skepticism I understand that people have
that sense I'll tell you how I thought
about it and think about it one again it
was a moving Target so there was a point
in the timeline where
it was totally rational to expect that
the vaccines
were were both working but both they
were
they were reasonably safe and that and
that covid was reasonably dangerous and
that the trade-off for basically
everyone was it was rational to get
vaccinated given how many given the
level of testing and how many people had
been vaccinated before you given what we
were seeing with covid right
um that that was a forced choice you're
either gonna you're eventually going to
get coveted and the question is do you
want to be vaccinated when you do right
there was a period where that forced
choice where it was just obviously
reasonable to get vaccinated
in especially because there was every
reason to expect that while it wasn't a
perfectly sterilizing vaccine it was
going to knock down transmission a lot
and that matters and so it wasn't just a
personal choice you were actually being
a good citizen when you decided to run
whatever risk you you were going to run
to get vaccinated because there are
people in our society who can't actually
can't get vaccinated I mean I know
people who can't take any vaccines
they're so they're so allergic to I mean
they they in their own person seem to
justify all of the fears of the
anti-vaxx cult I mean it's like they're
the kind of person who Robert Kennedy Jr
can point to and say see vaccines are
will [__] kill you right because
because of the experience it and they
and were still they I know people who
have kids who fit that description right
so
um we should all feel a civic
responsibility to be vaccinated against
egregiously awful and transmit
transmissible diseases for which we have
relatively safe vaccines
to keep those sorts of people safe and
there was a period of time when it was
thought that the vaccine could stop
transmission yes and so again all of
this is it has begun to shift
um I don't think it has shifted as much
as Brett Weinstein thinks it's shifted
but yes there are safety concerns around
the MRNA vaccines
especially for young men right as far as
I know that's the that's the purview of
the of of actual heightened concern
um but also
there's there's now a lot of natural
immunity out there a lot of basically
everyone who was going to get vaccinated
has gotten vaccinated the virus has
evolved to the point in in in this
context where
it seems less uh dangerous you know
again I don't I I I'm going more on on
the Siemens than on on Research that
I've done it at this point but I'm
certainly less worried about getting
covet I've had it once I've been
vaccinated I feel like it's like so you
ask me now how do I feel about getting
the next booster
I don't know that I'm going to get the
next booster right so so I I was
somebody who was waiting in line at four
in the morning you know hoping to get
get a some overflow vaccine when it was
first available and I that was at that
point given what we knew
or given what I thought I knew based on
the best sources I could consult and
based on
you know based on anecdotes that were
too Vivid to ignore you know both data
and and personal experience
um
it was totally rational for me to to
want to get that vaccine as as soon as I
could
and now I think it's totally rational
for me to to do a a different kind of
cost benefit analysis and wonder listen
do I really need to get a booster right
you know like how many of the how many
of these boosters am I going to get for
the rest of my life really and how safe
is the MRNA vaccine for a man of my age
right and do I need to be worried about
myocarditis for you know all of that is
completely rational to talk about now
my concern is that
at every point along the way
I was the wrong person and and Brett
Weinstein was the wrong person and
there's many other people I could add to
this list to have strong opinions about
any of this stuff I just disagree with
that I think
yes in theory I agree 100 but I feel
like experts failed at communicating not
at doing they did I I and I just feel
like you and Brett Weinstein actually
have the tools with the internet given
the engine you have in your brain of
thinking for months at a time deeply
about the problems that face our world
that you actually have the tools to do
pretty good thinking here it's the
problem I have with that but there would
be deference to experts and pseudo
experts behind all of that well the
papers you would stand on the shoulders
of giants but you can surf those
shoulders better than the Giants
themselves but I knew we were going to
disagree about that like I I I saw his
podcast where he brought on these
experts who had many of them had the
right credentials but for a variety of
reasons they didn't pass the smell test
for Me Maybe One larger problem this
goes back to the the problem of of how
we rely on Authority and science is that
you can always find a PhD or an MD
to to Champion any crackpot idea right
you could I mean it is amazing but you
could find phds and MDS who would sit up
there in front of Congress and say that
they thought smoking was not addictive
you know or that it was not harmful to
you know there was no direct link
between smoking and lung cancer you
could always find those people and you
could end so but you know some of the
people Brett found were people who had
obvious tells to my point of view to my
eye I mean and I saw them on some of the
same people were on Rogan's podcast
right and
um
and it's hard because if a person does
have the right credentials and they're
not and they're not saying something
floridally mistaken and we're talking
about something where
it's they're genuine unknowns right like
how how much do we know about the safety
of these vaccines right it's it's at
that point not a whole hell of a lot I
mean we have no long-term data on mRNA
vaccines
but to confidently say that millions of
people are going to die because of these
vaccines and to confidently say that
Ivermectin is a Panacea right Ivermectin
is the thing that prevents covet right
there was no good reason to say either
of those things at that moment and
that's and then and so given that that's
where Brett was
I felt like there was there was just no
there was nothing to debate we were both
the wrong people to get be getting into
the Weeds on this we're both going to
defer to our
chosen experts his experts look like
crackpots to me and
um
or at least the ones who are most
vociferous on those most on those
edgiest points it seemed most and your
experts seem like what is the term Mass
hysteria I forgot that well no but it's
like it's like with you know climate
science I mean this this old uh it's
received as a Canard for for in half of
our society now but the claim that 97 of
climate scientists agree that human
cause climate change is a thing right so
do you go with the 97 most of the time
or do you go with the three percent most
of the time
it's obvious you go with the 97 most of
the time for anything that matters it's
not to say that the three percent are
always wrong again the the there are
things get overturned and yes
as you say I've spent much more time
worrying about this on my podcast than
I've spent worrying about covid are
institutions have lost Trust
for good reason right and and it's it
it's an open question whether
we can actually get things done with
this level of transparency and and
pseudo-transparency given our
information ecosystems like can we fight
a war
really fight a war that we may have to
fight like the next Nazis can we fight
that war when everyone with an iPhone is
showing just how awful it is that that
little girls get blown up when we drop
our bombs right it's like could we could
we as a society do what we might have to
do
to get actually get necessary things
done when we're living in this this
panopticon of just you know everyone's a
journalist right everyone's a scientist
Everyone's an expert everyone's got
direct contact with the facts or or some
or a semblance of the facts I don't know
I think yes and I think voices like
yours are exceptionally important and I
think there's certain signals you send
in your ability to steal me on the other
side in your empathy essentially
so that's the fight that's the mechanism
by which you resist uh
the dogmatism of these this binary
thinking and then if you become a
trusted person that's able to consider
the other side then people will listen
to you as as the aggregators the
communicator of expertise because the
virologists haven't been able to be good
communicators I still to this day don't
really know
what is the what am I supposed to think
about the
um safety and efficacy of the vaccines
today as it stands today right what are
we supposed to think what are we
supposed to think about testing what are
we supposed to think about the
effectiveness of masks or lockdowns
where's the great communicators on this
topic that consider all the other
conspiracy theories all the other all
the communication that's out there
and actually aggregating it together and
be able to say this is actually what's
most likely the truth and also some of
that has to do with humility
epistemic humility knowing that you
can't really know for sure
just like with depression you can't
really know for sure yeah where is the
I'm not seeing those Communications
being effectively done even still today
well I mean the jury is still out on
some of it and again it's a moving
Target and and some of it I mean it's
complicated some of it's a
self-fulfilling
uh Dynamic where like so like lockdowns
in theory lockdowns a lockdown would
work
if we could only do it but we can't
really do it and there's a lot of people
who won't do it because they're
convinced that it's a this is the
totalitarian boot you know on finally on
the neck of the of of of
the good people who um
uh are always having their interests
introduced by the elites right so like
this is if you have enough people who
think the lockdown for any reason in the
face of any conceivable illness right is
just code for the new world order coming
to [__] you over and take your guns
right okay you have a society that is
now immune to reason right because
they're they're absolutely certain
pathogens that we should lock down for
next time right and and and it was
completely rational in the beginning of
this thing to lock down given to attempt
to lock down we never really locked down
to attempt some semblance of lockdown
just to quote bend the curve to spare
our health care System
given what we were seeing happen in
Italy right like that moment was it was
not hard to navigate at least in in my
view it was obvious at the time in
retrospect my views on that haven't
changed except for the fact that I
recognize maybe it's it's just
impossible given the nature of people's
response to that kind of
Demand right we live in a society that's
just not going to lock down unless the
pandemic is much more deadly right so
that's a point I made which you know was
maliciously clipped out from some other
podcast where someone's trying to make
it look like I want to see children die
look there's a Pity more children didn't
die from covet right
um this is uh it was actually the same
person who who uh and that's the other
thing that got so um
poisoned here it's like that person this
this psychopath or effective psychopath
who's creating these clips of me on
podcasts the second clip of me
uh seeming to say that I wish more
children died during covet which but it
was it was so I was so it was so clear
in context what I was saying that even
the clip betrayed the context so it
didn't actually work this psycho and
again I don't know whether he actually
is a psychopath but he's behaving like
one because of the incentives of Twitter
this is somebody who Brett signal
boosted as a as a very reliable source
of information right he he kept
retweeting this guy at me against me
right and this guy at one glance I knew
how unreliable this guy was right but I
think I
I'm not at all set one thing I think I
did wrong one thing that I do regret one
thing I have not sorted out for myself
is how to navigate the the
professional and personal pressure
that gets
applied at this moment where you have a
friend or an acquaintance or someone you
know
who's behaving badly in public or or
Behaving Badly behaving in a way that
you think is bad in public
and they have a public platform where
they're influencing a lot of people and
you have your own public platform where
you're constantly getting asked to
comment on what this this friend or or
acquaintance or colleague is doing
I haven't known what I think is
ethically right about the choices that
seem forced on us and at moments like
this so like I've criticized you in
public about your interview with Kanye
now in the case in in that case I
reached out to you in private first and
told you exactly what I thought and then
when I was going to get asked in public
or when I was touching that topic on my
uh podcast I more or less said the same
thing that I said to you in private
right now that was how I navigated that
moment
um I did the same thing with you with
Elon uh at least on at the beginning
um
you know this we have we have maintained
Good Vibes that was just which is not
what another Elon but I don't think I I
disagree with you because Good Vibes in
the moment there's a deep core of Good
Vibes that persists through time between
you and Elon and I would argue probably
between some of the other folks you
mentioned I I think with Brett I failed
to reach out in private
uh to the degree that I should have and
we never really had a we we had tried to
set up a conversation in private that
that never happened but
um there was some communication but
it would have been much better for me to
have made more of an effort in private
than I did before it's Spilled Out into
public and I would say that's true with
other people as well